affaire grégory deuxième journée de la
reconstitution du meurtre du petit
grégory villemin une hypothèse qui
relance instruction on s'était peut-être
trompé jusqu'à présent sur l'heure du
crime
le crime a en effet pu être commis
beaucoup plus tard qu'on ne le pensait
jusqu'ici
car le corps du petit grégory auraient
été jetés dans la vologne beaucoup plus
en aval
fr3 nancy grégory a été jetée à l'eau
dans le centre de dos elle il aurait été
techniquement difficile de le faire
ailleurs ce premier résultat de la
reconstitution
révélée par les avocats découle des
observations et des premières
conclusions du professeur marc un
médecin légiste expert près la cour de
cassation
le président simon avait pratiquement
organisé pour lui le déplacement de ce
matin à 2 celle là il a entendu albert
villemin les pompiers qui avaient
découvert le corps de l'enfant et les
gendarmes qui avaient quelques jours
après le drame tentait de reconstituer
le trajet du petit corps la température
de l'eau les courants toutes ces données
ont été une nouvelle fois relevé afin
que soient déterminées avec certitude le
lieu et l'heure de la mort de grégory la
première indication du professeur marin
est plus que favorable à la défense
puisque elle va à l'encontre de la thèse
établi par les polices est lancé
al'inverse les témoignages des collègues
de travail de christine villemin qui
affirme l'avoir vue devant la poste de
lépanges le 16 octobre 84 reste des
éléments à charge contre la mère de
grégory scie témoignage que le président
simon a réentendu cet après midi trois
ans presque jour pour jour est
pratiquement à la même heure 16h50
il a conduit la reconstitution de la
sortie de l'usiné et du trajet de ces
témoins primordiaux jusqu'à la poste de
lépanges un élément à décharge le matin
un élément à charge l'après midi dans le
cadre et dans les conditions du drame le
président simon ont conduit son
instruction comme s'ils étaient au
premier jour de l'enquète et chaque
étape de cette reconstitution devrait
lui permettre d'avancer vers la vérité
qui selon ses dires se trouve dans le
dossier